braves have a chance to get back to 500
here tonight and boy you always like
your chances when you give the ball to a
guy like max freed who's been terrific
in his last few starts and runners on
first and third nobody out at juan soto
coming up free to the belt the kick in
the pitch low it away that gets away
from contrast the catcher turner breaks
from third he'll come in to score
harrison to second base in the nationals
lead one to nothing
finally getting out on top of the first
inning run
and a one and two count on soto the
pitch swung on missed
went upstairs with 97 and there's that
strikeout
first of the game for freed
harrison at second with one away
zimmerman stepping into the right-hand
banners box
strike three outside corner at the knees
perfect pitch
fastball 97 back-to-back k's for max
freed
so harrison still at second base with
two away and it brings up castro
and here comes freed swinging a miss
he struck him out steven strasburg will
be on the mound for the nationals he'll
make his fifth start of the year a one
and two record of 4.43 era the nationals
find themselves 21 and 29. and ronald
acuna is coming up with a four-game
hitting streak in his back pocket 3-0
delivery two high ball four
and that one at 90 miles an hour and not
close
here we go something didn't look right
right from the start with strasberg and
nationals director athletic
training paul assard out there with
manager davey martinez is
as soon as strasbourg went for that walk
behind the mound
already something didn't seem right
and they weren't wasting any time going
out there to check on him the braves
have the time run at third base with one
man out and always at the plane
two balls and a strike on all these here
it is
line drive down the left field line
that's in for a base hit acuna will trot
home look at ozzy runner on first going
to second the throw by schwarmer is
late rbi double for ozzy all these and
we are back to even one a piece
so two outer runner at second and
dansby swanson the batter he's been the
hottest braves hitter a nine game inning
streak
now to 1-2 swinging a miss struck him
out
elevated fastball at 89 miles an hour so
strasberg gets through the inning a walk
of steel ahead
brings up strasbourg runner at second
and one out
creed trying to solve strasbourg here
with a 2-2 pitch here it is
off speed steering three
dropped a great big yakker on it
fourth strikeout for freed
so two going on the top of the second
trey turner at the plate 1-1 game top of
the second
another 2-2 pitch swinging a mess he got
him
big pitch by max free
got the 97 past him
hey turner
struck out four times yesterday that's
his first k today
and max fried
able to avoid damage in what was a
troublesome top of the second and it'll
bring up william contreras the rookie
catcher
hitting 239 in 21 games a double to
triple five homers and
17 runs batted in
down in the zone strasbourg knocks it
down barehand he's got time and
zimmerman makes a good pick on the
backhand side
steven strasberg taking the brunt
of a line drive right at him
he didn't look comfortable he didn't
look happy
i mean he looked miserable out there
from just the body language and facial
expressions
and here we go again with strasbourg and
whatever the ailment might be at this
point so
new pitcher with strasbourg leaving due
to injury will have as much time as he
needs to get ready to ronaldo [ __ ] here
in the first inning you can see
to me you see him shaking his arm here
the second pitcher second time right
here you really see it watch him try to
shake this thing out and what to me you
see look at that it's just the ball's
doing nothing right it's got no life on
it i think that's when davey martinez
came and i think the biggest thing is
whether it's a dead armor there was no
life on the fastball
we always see him that ball is sinking
he cooking it over 90. and now here
comes
acuna with first base open
and freeman on deck
the kick in the pitch swing and a miss
foul tip actually into the glove of both
for strike three on a climbing 95 mile
an hour fastball
starland castro
right-handed batter shift is on
check of the runners and the one-two
pitch swung on missed
got him with a fastball in and his
strikeout number six for free
two men out in the third six strikeouts
for freed and it's up to schwarber
but a good at bat and drew a walk
and made it to third lasting but was
stranded
the 0-1
here's the swing of the ground ball
right side and through for a base hit
through the shift headed toward the play
de soto acuna's throw home is offline
and not in time
nationals take the lead 2-1 rbi single
to right field for schwarber zimmerman
stops at second schwarber has his 24th
rbi
and the nationals have the lead back two
to one here's gomes two runs on four
hits for the nats one run one hit for
the braves hard hit ground ball right to
third reilly has it he'll run to the bag
at third after a hesitation
and accept the force out
damage limited to one run here's soto
two on and two outs
to one coming home fastball hit to left
field on a line that's a base it toward
the line
scoring is both head of the plate is
harrison hilf scores the throw is cut
off by riley it's a two run single left
for juan soto and the nationals lead
four to one big clutch hit for soto rbis
17 and 18 and the nationals now lead by
three the nationals have the 4-1 lead
with ryan zimmerman facing edgar santana
and to greet him ryan zimmerman deep
right center
[Applause]
see
you
later
opposite field zimmerman's sixth of the
year
and the nationals on the first pitch
lead six to one
both ready acuna in the box
yet another 3-2 pitch
from vote to acuna swung on and belted
that was solid ronald's taking a look at
that to straight away center god
that was mashed
braves back in it it's 6-3
home run number 17 for ronald rbi is 34
and 35.
a lot of room for swanson on the right
side
there goes riley the pitch swung on hit
to left field base it that'll get
albie's in riley's around second he'll
make third dansby with a huge turnaround
first he'll have to hold there wasn't it
bad he fell behind owen two
worked the count full and lined a rbi
single to left he extends his hitting
streak to ten games
and it's now six to four
chance to tack on an insurance run or
more here
with kyle schwarber
facing the lefty matsic
here's the old one
swinging a line drive left field this
one hangs up and a shoestring grab
attempted by almonte but he trapped it
so it's a base hit
soto will score from third castro into
second and it's an rbi single the other
way for schwarber nationals leads seven
to four
two on and one out
for john gomes
three balls one strike
here comes the pitch home
swinging a fly ball left center field
this one toward the gap way back there
toward the track and it's off the wall
gloved by heredia headed home is castro
schwarber trying to score swanson's
relay throw hits the side of the mount
it's not in time and in a second with a
two-run double is john gomes big hit for
the nationals they lead it nine to four
gomes picks up rbis 15 and 16 with that
drive to deep
left center field
here's robles seventh man to bat in the
inning victor a walk and two strikeouts
high fly ball
left field playable almante to his left
circles under he's there he's got it and
that will end the inning
and here comes austin reilly
smoke to the left side turner scrambles
throws to first and not in time infield
hit put it in play something good might
happen give riley a hit and an rbi
so here's almonte runner second and
third
the tall right-hander to the belt
and to the plate
strike three called outside corner of
the knees one out and turner at first
the banner will be juan soto now
soto to left center on a fastball
c
u
later bang zoom goes soto with his fifth
homerun of the year his third hit of the
night
this is a two-run blast giving him four
runs batted in for the night frames are
in the shift against schwarber
dayton peaks to second comes back to the
plate with a 2-2 swinging a mess at a
breaking ball
and runners at the corners now with one
out
with austin riley coming up next
high fly ball to center field didn't get
it though
hit it too high in the air still coming
down catches made by robles tagging at
third and coming into score is acuna on
the sac fly by riley dansby swanson the
last hope for the braves it'll be
another 3-2 to swanson swung on hit in
the air to deep left field back goes
schwarber the wall makes the catch
in the webbing of the glove and holds on
and a curly w is in the books